[Music]
Thomas Alva Edison my boys and I caught
in a jar but before now is only last
across the night sky the future is here
hello I'm George Westinghouse Nikola
Tesla I will leave a great this provider
electrical power in the world better
than Edison there's a contest between
you this is a battle for the brightest
minds of America today the impossible
becomes possible and the man that
controls that current controls the
future
I hope you brought your checkbooks you
want to be remembered it's simple shoot
a president but if you prefer to have
what I call a legacy you leave the world
a better place than you found it you are
building miracles out of thin air I'm
working on something so new that the
world would never be the same
mr. Edison succeeds he will send us back
so far we may never recover sometimes we
have to work outside of the rules to get
was right
that is how you truly win it maybe I
belches in every venture but did I
mention that his systems lethal his
current kills people
he's playing dirty you can too
you can't see the real force that moves
things of it's not a CD sales of
torrents to currency this is costing
affords Westinghouse hey my motor that
is our future
you're fired
they're never gonna be anything named
Tesla ever again our futures not going
to pay for bricks for recovering I had
the better system Westinghouse Electric
shall endure the City of Light but I
built it already in my imagination it is
perfectly there is a possibility you'll
be putting in jeopardy the lives of 28
million people tonight things could
change
shake up her right
only one man would rise
so what you trade invent or fix problems
radiates
you